rangoon 12 mai il y a dix jours que le
cyclone nargis ça frappait le pays
dix jours c'est le temps qu'il nous a
fallu pour obtenir un visa de tourisme
et réussir enfin à entrer dans le pays
aujourd'hui encore la birmanie est
interdite aux journalistes
dans les rues de rangoon la vie semble
avoir repris son cours normal
l'électricité n'est toujours pas rétabli
mais l'armée à nettoyer les rues et fait
enlever les milliers d'arbres abattus
par le cyclone dans les embouteillages
des vendeurs ambulants proposent
cigarettes journaux locaux mais aussi la
nouveauté du moment
le dvd exclusif du cyclone
[Musique]
le dvd du cyclone un match qu'ils aiment
bien
milchior un dollar
et voici son contenu des images rares
films et le plus souvent clandestinement
par des birmans
au coeur du cyclone
des vents qui soufflent à 240 km heure
des trombes d'eau et dans les région du
delta un raz-de-marée qui dévaste tout
sur son passage
[Musique]
au lendemain du drame ces images
montrent l'ampleur des destructions
les caméramen amateurs ont filmé les
survivants a garé devant leur village en
ruine et leurs vies dévastées
l'ouragan s'est abattu sur une région
qui compte plus de 20 millions
d'habitants
il y a eu des dizaines de milliers de
morts
[Musique]
selon l'onu il y aurait aujourd'hui 2,4
millions de sinistrés
[Musique]
sans abri sans médicaments et sans rien
pour reconstruire
isolé sur des bouts de terre dans ce qui
fut le grenier à riz de la birmanie
mais aujourd'hui il est impossible de
connaître l'étendue réelle du désastre
depuis des semaines aucun étranger n'est
autorisé à se rendre sur place
le peuple birman vit une tragédie une
tragédie caché au reste du monde
[Musique]
pour savoir ce que sont devenus les
victimes du cyclone
seule solution quitté rangoun et
s'enfoncer dans la campagne birman
le cyclone nargis a ravagé le sud du
pays la région du delta de l'irrawaddy
là dans son sillage il a provoqué un
raz-de-marée qui a littéralement
recouvert la région
c'est donc là qu'il faut se rendre pour
comprendre la tragédie que vit le peuple
birman mais la zone est interdite aux
étrangers
nous louons une voiture et un guide
prêts à nous accompagner malgré les
risques qu'ils courent nous tentons de
passer par l'une des trois routes qui
relient rangoon au delta de l'irrawaddy
à 30 km de la ville les militaires ont
établi un premier barrage
notre voiture est arrêtée
pendant qu'un policier relève les
identités du chauffeur et du guide les
militaires et tu dis mon passeport
la tente se prolonge elle va durer 10
minutes
je crois que c'est possible de négocier
de proposer de l'argent
non c'était pas possible je leur ai
parlé d'argent mais ça les a énervé pour
vous les étrangers
ce n'est pas possible de passer pour
passer il faut que vous demandiez une
autorisation au ministère de la défense
sinon vous pourrez pas passer trois
jours de suite
nous allons tenter de passer les
barrages sans succès de retour à rangoon
une solution s'impose faire venir de
paris une journaliste d'origine
asiatique
elle s'appelle thierry elle va se
déguiser en birman à billiers de la
tenue locale et le visage couvert de
tanaka le maquillage traditionnel elle
va tenter de descendre dans le sud du
pays
un chauffeur et un guide vont l'aider
vous ne verrez pas leur visage en aidant
une journaliste française il risque la
prison à la sortie de rangoun un premier
barrage
un policier soupçonneux les interroge le
guide lui explique que thiallier sa
soeur qu'elle est sourde et muette et
qu'elle a oublié sa carte d'identité
les ficelles sont un peu grosses mais ça
passe notre équipe vinci franchir tous
les autres barrages jusqu'au sud de pia
pon sans aucun incident
après 20 kilomètres de routes elle
découvre enfin ce que la junte birmane
veut cacher
des centaines des milliers de personnes
amassées au bord de la route attendant
qu'on leur vienne en aide
ils ont tout perdu comme cette femme
tous les jours elle marche deux heures
pour s'asseoir au bord de la route et
recevoir de quoi nourrir ses deux
enfants
toutes les maisons et les rizières de
son village ont été détruites
dormez ou la nuit au monastère où est le
père du bébé
il n'a plus de vêtements au monastère à
moi nu a prêté une rock mais ils n'osent
pas sortir avec on n'a pas dead
je ne peux pas reconstruire ma maison
pour la nourriture
je viens ici tous les jours c'est une
solution pour subsister mendier au bord
de la route
venez par ici s'il vous plaît face à
l'inertie de la junte birmane
la population se mobilise pour aider les
victimes
ce sont des gens des grandes villes qui
donne et nous nous distribuons
bénévolement
on distribue surtout du riz les
couvertures du savon et de l'huile je
viens de malade et j'ai fait neuf
kilomètres à pied pour venir aider les
gens
doucement y'en aura pour tout le monde
[Musique]
ne vous battez pas asseyez-vous je viens
je viens en birmanie la population a
pour coutume de nourrir ces moines en
leur faisant des offrandes
aujourd'hui celle inverse les moines
viennent au secours de la population
signe de l'ampleur de la catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand vous avez votre part vous pouvez
partir plus d'autres équipes descendent
dans la région de l'irrawaddy plus elle
découvre une population en exode
une file ininterrompue d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants qui attendent qu'on
les aide
tous les jours des particuliers et des
entreprises privées si l'yonne la route
avec des camions de vivres
sans eux la plupart des rescapés ne
pourrait pas se nourrir
[Applaudissements]
ici ce sont des jeunes venus de rangoon
ils se sont organisés entre amis pour
venir jusqu'ici
avec l'aide de leur employeur à rangoun
on collecte de l'argent et avec on
achète de la nourriture et des vêtements
et ensuite on va répartir tout ça dans
les sacs pour les distribuer
[Musique]
priorité aux personnes âgées des jeunes
solidaires et engagés mais qui n'osent
pas parler de l'attitude de leur
gouvernement
vous êtes au courant qu'il y à des aides
internationales
je préfère ne pas répondre
mais aujourd'hui la solidarité et la
générosité des birmans ne suffit plus
voilà ce qu'a donateurs a filmé depuis
son camion lors d'une distribution de
nourriture
oui
[Applaudissements]
trop de sinistrés pas assez dead une
vérité qui dérange les autorités
[Musique]
selon les ong seuls 20% des rescapés
aurait taxé aux dons
on est impuissant on n'a plus rien tout
ce qu'on attend c'est de l'aide
on veut de l'aide qu'elles soient
privées ou gouvernementales ou
internationale cette route est devenu le
seul lien des sinistrés avec le monde
extérieur
c'est grâce à elle qu'arrivent les aides
c'est donc la connaissance abri se sont
installés avec ce qu'ils peuvent
ils construisent des abris de fortune
les bidonvilles pouce aux bords de
l'arroux ici cinq familles vivent
ensemble sous la même temps il ya
combien d'enfants ici et 20 enfants si
l'adema et des enfants sont morts de
froid quelques jours après le cyclone
vous avez reçu des médicaments n'ont pas
encore la route est bonne on ne comprend
pas pourquoi les médicaments n'arrive
pas
les voilà
les autorités birmanes parle de
reconstruction
mais dans les faits c'est rarement le
cas dans ce village au sud de pia pon
seuls vingt maisons ont été
reconstruites sur les 426 qu'il comptait
auparavant
la saison des pluies est déjà là
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est de
reconstruire
personne n'a le temps de faire son deuil
ici 83 personnes sont mortes et 37 sont
toujours portées disparues
qu'on dit quand l'on est arrivé
la famille de mon beau frère a perdu
cinq personnes lui il a perdu son père
sa mère et sa petite soeur et son petit
frère on était en famille
j'avais mon petit frère de trois ans
dans les bras on a été embarqué par
l'eau on a été emporté très loin je ne
voyais plus rien on était sous l'eau une
vague a emporté mon petit frère je ne
pouvais plus le retenir
le lendemain j'ai cherché les corps mais
je n'ai trouvé personne
notre journaliste qui allie décide de
passer la nuit à pia pon pour descendre
le lendemain plus au sud dans le delta à
l'entrée de la ville un camp de tentes
du gouvernement a break il réellement
des réfugiés impossible de le savoir
elle ne peut pas s'arrêter le camp est
gardé par des militaires
mais le voyage va s'arrêter là ap yapen
le soir la police contrôle l'hôtel où
l'équipe est descendue le guide craint
pour sa sécurité
la journaliste prend la décision de
rentrer sur rangoun
dès le lendemain
pendant ce temps à la télévision la
chaîne officielle birmane diffusent en
boucle des images des généraux visite
des camps modèles et des réfugiés sont
alignés au garde à vous et en le canton
de détailler le généralissime than shwe
a été accueilli et salué par le général
semengue au nom du peuple sinistré
toujours aucune image des sinistrés du
delta je décide de tenter à nouveau
d'atteindre ces zone interdite
après deux jours d'attenté finalement
des birmans se propose de me faire
passer clandestinement un rendez vous
est fixé dans la banlieue de rangoon
les passeurs sont en train de charger
une camionnette de vivre pour les
rescapés du cyclone
ils nous demandent 1000 $ pour le
passage
c'est le prix à payer pour les risques
qu'ils prennent en nous faisant passer
il ne reste plus qu'à se glisser dans la
cache aménagée derrière les caisses de
marchandises
durant tout le trajet 1 d'épaisseur
reste assis à l'arrière du camion au cas
où un militaire voudrait fouillé après
une vingtaine de kilomètres premier
contrôle
il faut se cacher sous une bâche et
attend
par chance le convoi n'est pas arrêté
nous allons ainsi passé sans aucun
incident les cinq contrôles qui
interdisent l'accès aux zones sinistrées
du delta
après cinq heures de route le convoi
stop au-dessus d'un pot
les pacers ont tout préparé un bateau
nous attend il va nous emmener au coeur
du delta de l'irrawaddy dans la région
que les militaires birmans veulent
cacher au monde
pendant des heures nous descendons l'un
des bras du fleuve irrawaddy mais pour
accéder au village dévasté
il faut s'engager dans l'un des
innombrables petits canaux qui irriguent
la région
[Musique]
ici le cyclone a tout détruit sur son
passage
[Musique]
mais cadavre de puch pourrissent dans
l'eau
[Musique]
partout une odeur de décomposition et de
pourriture
une odeur de mort
[Musique]
un peu plus tard au détour d'un canal
une immense bâtisse en ruine c'est un
monastère
c'est la première fois que les moines
voix des étrangers venir ici
ils veulent nous montrer les ravages du
cyclone dima au cas si oui est ce qu'il
ya eu des morts ici ici dans le village
il y a eu entre 60 et 70 morts on a eu
de la chance s'en est sorti vivant
l'eau est montée jusque là on a vraiment
eu de la chance en partant notre guide
distribuer de la nourriture
il a apporté avec lui des caisses
remplies de paquets de nouilles
déshydraté tout au long du voyage
il va les distribuer aux villageois
après six heures de bateau nous
atteignons l'un des villages isolés du
delta d'ailleurs les habitants sont
surpris
depuis le cyclone personne n'était
encore venu jusqu'ici le guide leur
explique pourquoi nous sommes là à son
retour ce journaliste va montrer votre
situation au monde extérieur
le mot chapeau et le chef de la
communauté
accompagné des autres habitants il nous
emmène dans son village sinistré un
village de 1300 personnes
des maisons détruites des habitants
hagards
certains sont visiblement en état de
choc de cette maison tous les murs se
sont envolés il ne reste que les meubles
et cette petite fille
le cyclone a provoqué un mini
raz-de-marée qui a recouvert toute la
région
quelle était la hauteur de la vague
la vague elle faisait près de quatre
mètres
l'eau a dépassé ces arbres elle est
arrivée jusqu'à notre maison
l'eau était pleine de sable et de bouts
de voir la vague a percuté la maison et
l'a emporté la barre beaucoup de femmes
et d'enfants sont morts ici
il leur suffisait d'avaler trois gorgées
d'eau et c'était fini pour ici ce sont
surtout les femmes et les enfants qui
sont morts au milieu du chemin des
bâches de plastique dans lesquels les
villageois ont mis en commun leurs
réserves de riz ils le font sécher
ce soir on doit manger que ça il n'est
plus très bon mais on va le manger quand
même le village et coupé de tout ce riz
c'est tout ce qu'on a pour survivre
quelques jours quand nous serons en
pleine saison des pluies
il ne restera plus rien on ne sait pas
comment on va réussir à survivre
vous avez reçu de l'aide du gouvernement
non pour l'instant aucune aide du
gouvernement
rien du tout les habitants veulent nous
montrer un autre village nous traversons
leurs rizières aujourd'hui submergées
par l'eau salée
elles sont inexploitables le village
auquel il nous amène a été complètement
détruit ici aucun arbre pour protéger
aucune barrière naturelle
les maisons ont été soufflées par le
cyclone la plupart des habitants sont
morts ou disparus
les survivants sont en état de choc
il n'y a plus rien avant c'était un
village
maintenant c'est un cimetière ma mère et
moi sommes les seuls rescapés de toute
ma famille est maintenant comment vous
voyez votre avenir
il n'y a plus rien à faire
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse on
n'a nulle part où aller
c'est une nouvelle vague arrive on
s'assiéra ici et on attendra ensuite le
chef du village nous entraîne vers l'un
des rares bâtiments encore debout
l'école transformée en refuge
là ce sont les rescapés du cyclone
nargis
c'est le refuge du village pour tous les
sinistrés
il ya combien de personnes ici il y en a
asseyez-vous les enfants ce sont des
amis
ultime espoir pour ces sinistrés le
gouvernement birman a finalement déclaré
sous la pression de l'onu qu'il
laisserait passer les ong étrangères
dans le delta
dans ces villages isolés dans la région
ils seraient aujourd'hui plus de deux
millions de réfugiés à attendre de
lèvres une aide qui ne vient toujours
pas
monde